Hello everybody. Hope that you are good.
Exciting day. Bitcoin is finally moving
up. So far for the past two weeks, we've
been correct with our projection and
right now we're in a very delicate area
where everything could change. And I
hope it does and it gets invalidated.
But all I want to say in this video is
well, we're going to be analyzing
whether if this is a breakout or if this
is a potential liquidity rune. But most
important than that because at the end
of the day that's just my guess and I
cannot trade based on my guess. Uh for
that we still need a lot more
information like today's daily candle
close the weekly candle close is also
very important and a lot of more context
okay to jump into conclusions. But most
important than that we're going to be
analyzing my triggers. This is something
that I do every day that I trade or in
this case that I'm looking more for like
a swing trade. It's something that I do
almost in a weekly basis and it's when
I'm going into a position. All right, so
that's what I'm going to be doing during
this video and I'm going to share it
with you. But uh so far for the past two
weeks, what we've been saying is that
from the mid-range, price could go up
into the local resistance around 94,300.
You can see the area was at very strong
resistance. It got respected. We saw a
small rejection, a retrace, then from
there a push higher and this move up. I
was not sure. It was not certain that it
was going to happen. So far, it's
happening. We are seeing that potential
move that I defined as a potential
liquidity rune. But again, this could be
a breakout. That's what we're going to
be analyzing. And from here, we need to
be cautious because if this is a
liquidity rune, a liquidity rune, I'll
say very quickly what it is. Again, a
liquidity rune is a false move into one
direction
before price moves into the opposite
direction. that that would be the real
move. Okay. And this liquidity rune is
done just to gather more liquidity
before pulling the real move because
that would be much more efficient in
terms of liquidity. You have to
understand that for the past weeks we've
been saying that around 96K there were a
lot of liquidations and this is a
screenshot taken from today. You can see
the liquid the short liquidations around
96K. Today they've all been hit the this
long week has been so precise that it
hit all these yellow lines. You can see
that after the week it tends to be more
more blue. Sorry. And that means that
there are less liquidations but that
long week was so precise and it hit
exactly those liquidations. Okay. From
there now price is stabilizing not
giving us much of an idea of what is
happening. So we have to remain cautious
because if you are going to open a long
right now, you need to understand that
you are opening a long right below a
very strong resistance which is the
weekly 50 MA. So obviously based on my
um trading style and my rules, I cannot
open a long right now right below a high
time frame resistance. However, if price
starts to break through the weekly 50
MA, that's a very good sign. But if it
breaks through 100K then we are good.
Okay. I I would assume that we are good.
The price would likely create um a new
support at 100K like it did previously
and this would be some kind of uh
retrace accumulation price goes back up.
Okay. Um yeah. So basically 100K is my
validation level. If we get back above
100K then I'll only be favoring longs.
It does crystal clear to me. But right
now that we are right below the quickly
50 May price is at 97,630
right now and the high transfer
resistance is at 97,660.
All right. So we are literally testing
the resistance right now. No point in
opening the long because it's too much
risk. Yes, price can break out because I
can see momentum but wait until we clear
that resistance. That at least is my
personal opinion. No financial advice.
That's what I'm uh thinking. I don't see
worth it to open a position um a long
position right now. Need a short because
if you open a short right now, you are
opening a short against the trend and
against momentum. So
it's a bad idea really. Also, you have
to understand that depending on what
traders do now, price is going to do one
thing or another. And and by this I mean
that if many traders are starting to
open shorts right now because they are
expecting I don't know the the Trump
tariffs get cancelled by by Congress
this week and a lot of traders start to
open shorts then all those shorts that
are speculating all those shorts are
adding fuel for price to go to continue
going up they're adding fire to the
momentum. All right. So that's also
going to play an important role. But uh
my triggers I would tell you if price
breaks above 100K then all this idea
gets invalidated. Okay gets invalidated.
Um I will be looking to open new longs
from 100K. Uh because I would be
expecting price to go higher which
either way is what I'm expecting for
2026. As I said I'm very bullish on
2026. There is a lot of liquidity
flowing into the market and everything
uh that I see in the macro context
points to gold going higher, silver
going higher, copper going higher,
bitcoin going higher, hard assets going
higher against the trash fiat currencies
that we have. So that's what I'm
expecting for 2026. But in the short
term, we need to be careful. Wait, or
this is what I'm doing. I'm waiting for
100k to be clear. Once price breaks
above 100K, then I'm back into longs in
confidence. But right now, be careful
because this could be a liquidator run.
All right, we could see bad news
tomorrow and this move might know that
we're going to get bad news and that
would also be part of this liquidity
run. So, be careful. Now, my trigger,
I'm opening a short here. I would open a
short only if price
drops from around the weekly 50 MA back
inside this range back below 94,300.
That is the moment that I would be
opening an a short. Okay. And I would be
targeting around 83K to 80K. But again
for that I need price to turn around
here and first drop back inside the
range. So, I will be probably opening my
shorts around 94,000 93,500. Okay, not
from now. I don't care to miss this
move. Okay, I just want to open it with
the lowest risk possible. Okay, and
right now here I think it's very risky
to open shorts because you are fighting
against momentum. Although you are below
resistance, but there is momentum. So,
there could be a breakout. And it's very
silly also to open a long because you
are right below a very strong high time
frame resistance. Okay, so I need more
information. That's the way that I'm
trading this. So in conclusion, to open
a long, I want price to trade above 100K
and to open a short, I want price to
drop back below 94,300.
And also guys I want to mention this
because it's very important and it's
been playing out and it was that if you
remember when we were around this area
here around 84 85 we were saying that
careful because at 90k there are a lot
of call options and all these call
options what they are doing is not
letting price to break out because the
dealers are forced to sell. So at the
end you have a very tight range because
if price goes up the dealers are forced
to sell and when price drops down they
are forced to buy. So at the end you
have a range and that's what we saw in
this area. Okay. Then I told you that
those options were going to expire and
they were going to be a record level of
of amounts of volume. Once that happened
then we are starting to see more
volatility.
But this is what is important. I've
noticed that 100K
there are a lot of call options again.
They are selling call options and that
means that at 100K
price is likely
to struggle to break through because
dealers are forced to sell. And when are
these options expiring? The 31st of
January. So really we only have two
weeks for those call options to expire.
price could go towards 100k then reject
but after the 31st of January then price
can break through. Okay, so careful with
that because that's also going to add
kind of a bit of downwards pressure
because as I said price is likely not
going to break through 100k before the
end of the month because of these call
options. Um
that's pretty much everything that I
want to say guys. um it's a liquidity
rune. It could be it's not invalidated
until invalidated away. And for that we
need price first to go to 100K to
invalidate this idea. As long as it
doesn't do that, then this idea, this
projection is still alive. So we need to
remain cautious. All right. Again, I'm
not in a long. I'm not opening shorts.
I'm waiting for price to either break
through 100K. to me that it's a long and
I'm waiting also for price to drop back
below the local resistance because that
would mean that this was a deviation
that was a liquidity rune price is
likely to trade back inside the range
and until the range lows and that would
be where I would be opening a short okay
if price drops right below 94,300 again.
So thank you so much guys for listening.
I don't want to take much of your time
and I'll see you soon.